again with phil heath
with adam sauce and gerard lots of new
topics to cover
adam right off the bat as i'm going
through the topic says adam tell me
what's your number one topic adam says i
demand we start with kyrie irving so
we're gonna start off with kyrie irving
now tell me why kyrie was your top story
what what i just think he's
he's very topical right now you you
brought up something
last episode where you showed up your
last tweet i don't know if it's your
last tweet you said
the guy said pat i don't i don't know
what to make you at this point yeah i
don't get you
you know i i agree with you and then i
don't agree with you it's a very good
point and it's just like what am i
supposed to do with you yep and i feel
like that's what people are dealing with
kyrie right now
i remember when we first started doing
the podcast i can't believe we're almost
on episode 100 four away yeah four away
my you know my math uh you know it was
almost off but it's four ways it's so
funny but i remember it's so funny
people especially on the right yeah
were very angry with kyrie during the
social justice okay situation he was
very vocal about blm he was very vocal
about
um voicing his opinions and a lot of
people
not to get very political here but a lot
of people that obviously tend to be on
the right side of the equation [ __ ]
kyrie this and that
and now that he's sort of anti-vaxxed
they're like well i i kind of hated
kyrie but now i kind of agree with him
and who though i think obviously the
anti-vaxx community or the people that
you know
you mean the pro-choice community
is that what they're calling it these
days that's great verbiage that's a
great wait wait a minute that's no
choice right i mean they're pro-choice
they're sure so choice community so now
you see how weird politics is exactly
you see how weird how it backfires on
you too though
i'm bringing up a point that you brought
i know i agree with you and by the way
here's the thing do you think i'm a
kyrie fan
i do not think you're a kind i'm not
have i ever been a kairi fan not his
game his game entertaining like i will
watch that uncle drew stuff over and
over again i think the guy is sick right
but am i a fan of his style of no no no
i'm not it's very look at me look at me
look at me look at me but here's the
problem matter of fact let me just read
the story and then we'll go into it so
here's a story about kyrie
he will not practice or play with the
brooklyn nets due to a vaccination
status this is a cnn story brooklyn
general manager sean marx has confirmed
kyrie irving will not play or practice
with the team until he is eligible to be
a full participant as issues relating to
the star guards vaccination status
continues head coach steve nash has
admitted that his team will be without
kai rebound for foreseeable home games
but masks mark said that the nets would
not allow a member of the team to be
part-time then that's one the the nba
warned the nets as well as the new york
knicks and golden state warriors in
september that the new covenant policy
set by the local governments will
prohibit any unvaccinated player from
playing in the home games in new york
city in san francisco okay fantastic so
here's where i go with this
to me
kyrie irving is colin kaepernick
kyrie irving to me is colin kaepernick
he is
taking a kneel he's saying i don't stand
with what you stand for
you're forcing me to stand up and i
don't want to do it and colin kaepernick
was what a hero because he didn't want
to do what the government was telling
him to do
but because the government's telling
kyrie what to do in a vaccine and the
nba agrees with it he's now a villain so
let's now ruin his reputation and he's
going to have to come play and get
vaccinated there is no difference
between him and colin kaepernick so the
part that that is annoying in this book
where i understand why people are
getting annoyed is i watched stephen a
yesterday you know we've had steven aon
and i've interviewed stephen and i'm a
big fan of steven a i'm not it's not
this is not like i don't so i watch if i
have if i want to get someone's take
on any topic i go stephen a yeah you're
a big fan i like steven ace and i i go
to and i look at him like stephen a what
are you saying what are you talking
about like what do you mean this is
championship this is championship really
so go back to five years ago when
everybody was talking about colin
kaepernick kneeling this is bad for the
team they can't win a championship they
had a championship squad it's not about
championships it's about what you stand
for it's about what's right for you it's
about this wait a minute you can't take
it one place or the other by the way
you're right that the left and the right
do this all the time but in this
situation here to me kyrie irving is the
new colin kaepernick except the new
colin kaepernick kyrie is being treated
differently than colin kaepernick colin
was a hero kyrie's a villain well i
think in many cases kaepernick was also
a villain you know to the game of sports
to the game of sports in the sports
world yeah
colin was a hero
let's not get it twisted in the world of
sports colin is a hero nike did a
massive contract 40 million all that
stuff but kyrie completed you know
something that
that you brought up when um when we were
talking about the kaepernick stuff
earlier this was before you guys really
graced us being on the podcast you said
that it was on roger goodell that he he
messed up one million percent that he
messed up he should have intervened real
quick like i said this is my league let
me embrace this guy let me talk to this
guy rather than like sweeping under the
rug yes so the question is
what should adam silver do at this point
it's not it's not on adam though but it
kind of isn't but he's the commissioner
but it's not on adam you have to tell
you what to do
because this is a law being passed down
by biden this is not a no no this is
local state this is our local government
fine but what's his golden state this is
brooklyn this is the bigger that even
validates my point
that validates my point even more what
i'm trying to say is then that's the
government it's not in adam's control
adam can't do anything about it adam has
to say you got to follow the law the law
of the land and the law of the land
where you're living is the government i
don't have any control over it just like
southwest airlines yesterday when the
story came out do you know how
everybody's like whoa southwest airlines
well they canceled because of the rain
they canceled because of whatever
they're claiming to cancel for right
and then the story comes up
where the ceo flat out comes out and
tells the story and i know these two
stories maybe don't have anything to do
are we moving on from kyrie i'm not i'm
staying on it we're going to come back
because i want to hear everybody but i
want to i want to read you what he said
so southwest ceo denies thousands of
flight cancellations were over vaccine
mandates blames absentism okay the
post-millennial story and then he goes
and says the seal gary kelly said he is
personally opposed to corporate vaccine
mandates but that the company had
complied with president biden's order
that all companies with over 100 workers
require those workers to be vaccinated
against covenanting what he's trying to
say is i don't support it but what do
you want me to do it's the law coming
down so adam silver cannot do nothing
about it because the local government is
saying you better get a vaccinated what
are your thoughts about this film oh my
gosh um
we talk about force and choice
non-freaking stop i have a question
and anyone could chime in what did we do
with magic johnson with the whole hiv
aids thing when he came back
he was able to play
yeah but a lot of the players did not
want to play with him it didn't matter
he voiced his opinions but he still
played yeah still played sick all-star
game that fade away three and look at
that and look at that moment we
celebrated this man yeah we continue to
do that through this day and that's a
little more serious i see where you're
going with this right so think about how
serious that was and what we're talking
about with this
i don't know guys i mean i i think it's
you know it's uh
by the way you make because clay travis
said that yesterday and i was looking at
clay travis when he said about magic
having aids and his twitter tweet went
viral and then i went at the bottom to
see the the what do you call it the
rebuttal to it right because i want to
know the rebuttal so the rebuttal was
there's a difference between aids and uh
covid because aids does not transf what
do you call it like you can't just get
it by playing back
but wait a minute i disagree because to
me what are you talking about you're
going like this you're doing this on all
of us you cut and you cut them we got to
cut we got blood so it can still happen
they changed the game with regards to
any time there's a player that has blood
on their uniform or shorts or whatever
they change the game with that still to
this day i mean yeah side note by the
way isn't it like do you know anybody
with aids at this point like other than
mad like there's
any like i feel like age i know in the
90s yeah
yeah but in the 90s that was like the
biggest thing in the world now i don't
even know anybody says people with aids
are living that's true that's the
difference so they they're in the
community they've got the the cocktail
yeah well just like how they have it now
right but they're not forcing certain
people my question also i have another
question is are we within those certain
states
are are there mandates for
attendees
to go watch or perform there are so
everybody has to show a card golden
state cannot go in new york specifically
you cannot go into a gym gymnasium gym
without showing a vaccination so so what
happened with your comedy show remember
no but i'm talking about like okay
golden state warriors like if i go to a
game we went to a game we'd have to show
a card and they'd have to scan it or
whatever yes wow yes this is very
interesting i mean you know um i'm in an
independent film that's coming out on
friday and
you know they they wanted me to come up
do the um
do like the whole premiere and stuff
like that good dude eric grooms great
greek dude movie called midlife and uh
i'm not going you know well i got things
to do here obviously but also i'm not
going because i couldn't i'm not [ __ ]
going i couldn't code i couldn't go to
the premiere of the movie that i'm in
yeah so
it is what it is man it is like at this
point is there anything
anything that would make you get the
vaccine at this point at this point no
i'll just be real at this point because
of everything they've done i wouldn't
get it out what is it a health issue
is it a political thing it's pure spite
and also no but here's the deal we have
allowed the goalposts to move so far
past what is beyond acceptable as far as
what government can and can't say about
our lives that dude i this is a hill i
am actually literally willing to die on
well let's not no i'm just saying i am
literally but i but i also don't really
feel that at risk
i feel like since you've lost 50 pounds
i feel like i'm having it thanks bro but
also i had it i had it when i was
morbidly obese and i still had a 98 9.7
chance of surviving so i'm not going to
give up 100 of my civil rights for
something that i have a 99.8 percent you
guys survived did you guys see joe rogan
with sanjay gupta yesterday yes you see
that that was
which he never does yeah he went on the
offensive for maybe i've been listening
to rogan for five years yeah i've never
seen him go on the offensive line but it
was impressive the way he asked the
question he said so do you feel at risk
when you go out and you know do your
thing and play you know live your life
just know because i'm vaccinated it says
great he says you being vaccinated have
the same amount of risk as a kid that's
not vaccinated but why are we forcing
kids to be vaccinated because out of
millions of kids only 5 500 kids have
died
and so you have the same ratio risk why
would we force the kids to get
vaccinated and he didn't have an answer
he was stuck because you know california
trying to talk to 18. he kept trying to
pivot also but he would joe wouldn't let
him win he wouldn't let that bulldog joe
crush it yesterday it was great yeah but
i gotta give uh
gupta credit for getting out there
taking the tough questions he he felt
like
joe at the beginning of the interview
was like how do you feel working for a
network that lies look yeah and and to
gup those credit he's like yeah they
shouldn't have said that and then joe
pressed them and pressed them and
probably wouldn't admit that they lie
either something that you say all the
time is
like something that's
that's a liable mission something that
trump does is he'll get on
opposite polarizing views and still
state his case so yeah
okay i get that but if you go on
opposing platforms and still lie on
those platforms you don't get credit
it's a liable mission it's very simple
did they lie about in vermectin well no
no well did well no that's not true he
says no he owned up to they said they
shouldn't have said that yeah pivot but
then he refused to talk about what's it
feel like about the net he refused to
talk about the network consistently
lying he could he refused
that's a tough situation to be in
the whole thing would line the whole
thing with lines cnn line yesterday uh
uh
van jones flat out i don't know if you
guys saw van jones yesterday i'm a fan
of ann jones as well although van jones
was a card carrying you know communist
years ago and all this stuff you know
when he was first linked to obama they
had to pull him out and say hey we can't
affiliate with you evan jones yesterday
said listen the honeymoon is over
biden's getting crushed okay and if they
continue this way it's not going to
happen he says the republican is united
republican parties united right now with
congress every one of them voted the
same way they just said that not a
single republican voted against the uh
what do you call what is it
that ceiling he says but the democrats
are in shambles right now okay and and
if they go the way they're going right
now it's not going to be a good midterms
it's not going to be this he says they
have 12 months to fix it but then chris
cuomo said the following chris cuomo
said he said van it doesn't matter
anyways because even if you guys go
there the opposing party is willing to
lie to your face just to get reelected
they're willing to compromise the
democracy of america and van gaal the
balls that's chris coleman was saying
that so so the point is on one and on
the same exact day when rogan comes out
with gupta saying yeah you know they
should have said that the network light
same day combo was saying everybody on
the other side lies so you know at the
end to be fair we could go on to fox
news and find all the lives
there is
do you okay this has got nothing to do
with the left or the right this has got
to do with the fact that one says the
other doesn't end the other doesn't we
don't that's the problem it's like no no
no we don't do it we're holy but they do
it no both of you have done it and both
of you have a hard time coming out and
saying i'm sorry we screwed up so this
is why they won't admit it this is why
when somebody comes out and says listen
we messed up you respect it
in the past and that is an argument that
is 100 true over the course of history
in this moment in this moment we are
living in very very specifically the
democratic party is in complete and
total control the progressive agenda is
everywhere
it's not some right-wing nut job that's
forcing kyrie irving to sit it's not the
pressure from the right wing that has
all of his teammates willing to hang him
out to dry not a single teammate saying
unless my boy kyrie is out here i'm not
going out there not a single one
but i don't but gerrard i i think it's
bigger than that and it's in i i i don't
think a teammate is not with them i
don't think a teammate's not with them
but i also don't think
there's only two teammates that have
this kind of money okay
you have there's a big difference
between having that kind of money look
you're making two million dollars in the
nba per year taxes half goals they're in
new york so you got one million left
after age and three hundred thousand
taking a job by the way two million
dollar your player in nba is netting 600
grand a year think about that it's not a
lot of money and that's before they got
to pay out to the agent all of this
stuff so so you just know they're not as
rich as people think they are it's a lot
of shows you're on the veteran's minimum
yeah the guys that are making money are
hardened you know durant these guys are
making superstars so i think there's a
part of it where these guys are so much
about walking on egg shows today just
the fact that lebron kudos to lebron in
this situation lebron came out and said
we made a decision as a family and we
chose to go with it guess what salute
good for you it is you and your family's
decision and then he said i believe this
is a decision that should be left to
to the individual to decide so here's a
question before we try to solve every
one of world's problems today do you
what do you think is gonna end up
happening to kyrie
well what's gonna happen to kyrie is he
look is he gonna die in the sword and
said i'm retiring because this is the
debate he returns retirement or do you
think he's gonna take the vaccine or do
you think he's going to get traded to
like a red state a couple different
things it's let me just say this very
clearly it's his choice personal choice
no mandates cool we're good with that
if he actually wants to use his voice
uh because that's what his whole thing
is have a voice i want to use it
i have this platform
look how quickly he's going to lose his
voice if he doesn't actually end up
playing basketball shut up and dribble
if i'm not saying it for to shut up and
dribble
talk all you [ __ ] want and dribble
but if you're not going to play
basketball people don't care about you
bro you're going to get more eyeballs
and more people listening to you when
you're balling out and you're scoring 28
a night and you're and people oh kyrie
did this
check out this film but think about it
here let me finish my point if he's not
going to play ball yeah and he doesn't
play ball for two years
i i don't see him even being in
headlines you think that he should do
something that he finds morally
repugnant in order to play a game
and make money from the game that he's
clearly one of the best in the holiday
how do you think he gets paid by doing
things that are morally repugnant how do
you think it gets paid he's paying
someone give you 200 million dollars
gerard michaels someone gave you 200
million
you wouldn't get the vaccine if you say
no you're an idiot
dude at some point there's something
more than money at some point there's
something on the line more than money
this is 200 million dollars to get a
proven vaccine come on figure this is
first of all it's not proven stop that
[ __ ] it's the last booster's not
even five months old i worked in pharma
sales we're not gonna know anything for
five years this might be a miracle
because you worked this morning sales
now you're an expert have you ever
watched anything late at night have you
took enver mcdaniel in 1922 you are
invited
you're asking what are your morals worth
you're asking how morally bankruptcy
is morals like you're saying that
everybody has a price wait wait wait
wait wait i let you talk the
nurses are making 200 million dollars
they're going to lose the job the
doctors are not making 200 million
dollars they're going to lose their job
the pilots you stop the pilots are not
making 200 million
they're going to lose their job this is
bigger than kyrie irving kyrie irving is
not standing up for kyrie irving he's
standing up for every single one of the
people in this entire world that are
being forced to do something that they
don't want to do by a government that
has lost its way
this is bigger than kyrie irving and
he's got money that he's already got
money man let's be real you're on the
side of forced if so there's no price
you like let's see treating this vaccine
like it's a bad thing let's stop
treating you let's stop trying it like
it's exactly what's the damn survivor i
think i think that i think i think by
the way
this exact how emotional this gets is
exactly how a lot of people are feeling
right now why is this even this heat
heated of a debate it's a choice do you
take it take it you don't take you don't
take it that's not a real
if it's going to make millions and
millions of dollars
he's already worth millions and millions
of dollars but guess what that's still
the guy's choice if he doesn't want to
do it i said at the top of the segment
it's his choice it's still his choice
it's also his choice play basketball
by the way you make a very valid point
because i'll give you the flip side of
it you know how people say stuff like if
i was tiger i would have never done that
with 16 different women and all this
stuff you know what i say to them you
know what i say to them
why don't you go
back to being two years old play golf
for 20 years become the greatest in the
world have every person in the world pay
attention to you try to go to walmart go
ahead go ahead and do it because right
now when you go to walmart the cashier
doesn't even look at you it's a big
difference so you don't know what it is
to be so we don't know what it is to be
tiger just like gerard doesn't know what
it is for the nets to say
here's 200 million take the vaccine he
doesn't know that you don't know that
none of us know that until you're put in
a situation like that's a very weird
situation to be in i had a board call
recently it was not a comfortable board
call on on this thing coming up i can't
openly talk about what the conversation
was about but it wasn't comfortable it's
a very difficult conversation and i said
look i'm the guy that left iran man i'm
about choices i'm here because i like
choices i don't like forces i like
choices and i fully support our guys
that are getting it and i fully support
the guys are not getting it what i don't
support is you not wanting to go educate
yourself whether you're the person
that's not and whether you're the person
that is i have guys that don't want to
get their seven-year-old parents uh
the shot and i said i just want you know
go do a little research on who this
thing helps based on where they're at i
support my dad got it my nanny got it
and not a single time have that gun
judged about it but i want to go back to
my question i didn't ask what he should
do
and then that's what he should do
because it's a different conversation
i'm asking what do you think he'll end
up doing what do you think will end up
happening to kyrie
do you think this is going to be a guy
that's going to go to the very end or do
you think this is going to be a guy
that's going to get traded do you think
he's going to be retiring or do you
think he's just going to take a year off
i think he might just take a year off
okay i think he's going to take it what
do you think he's going to do
look i'll say it again if you want to
not do this that's your choice
but we've all played
team sports you guys have okay well i
know you were the iranian dennis rodman
in high school you had never sharp
elbows i played team business but
look
selfishly as a miami heat fan i love
kyrie not playing because brooklyn nets
are the favorites so if we're gonna talk
sports
all right my heater looking pretty damn
good right now what do you think he's
gonna do not what do you think he should
i think he's look i've actually hung out
with kyrie before one of my best friends
is very close he's a works with the
celtics he represents marcus smart
and uh i've been out to dinner with them
i've gone to the club with them we've
had a private like boss take us around
i've hung out with kyrie legit cool guy
he does have a big ego sat at the head
of the table during dinner paid for the
whole check paid for everything i guess
if you're going to pay for everything
you're going to have that first of all
look dude there's not a lot of guys
if this guy plays 82 games versus any
other point guard playing in 82 games
he's a top three this guy is not so the
eagle comes with the amount of years he
practiced with his dad and the ego comes
with the territory but what do you think
he's gonna do i think
he
if i the point that i was gonna make is
if i'm his teammate i'm thinking look
bro
like we can't win this without you we're
going to need you to step up all of the
conversation what is he going to do i
don't think he's going to do it okay so
i think he's going to i think he's going
to take you
i think he's going to i think he's that
far into the situation what do you think
he's going to do that he's not going to
do all right let me ask you a question
kai from norway who won the nba
championship two years ago
two years ago the lakers okay i asked
kai
thanks
david who was the nba mvp three years
ago
uh jackie lebron
okay who's colin kaepernick
uh
qb okay
hey who
kai you're from norway right who's
martin luther king jr
he's the guy who stood up against racism
okay who's rosa parks
she didn't sit she didn't sit in the
back of the bus okay who won the nba mvp
in 1969. gosh who knows but you know
what the other two are yeah exactly some
things are being basketball stop
something's are bigger
now okay so kyrie is [ __ ] martin
luther king now you know rosa parks wait
dude stop it wait you're talking about
you're talking about because you won't
take a vaccine because somebody won't
sit in the back of the bus stop it bro
it's a seat on the same bus
shut up and do what you're told go to
the back of the bus shut up and do what
we tell you the fact that you're trying
to throw
martin luther king and rosa parks next
to a kind of freaking do what you're
told no that's not what i'm saying i
said from the get-go first of all you
can do whatever you want it's government
control that he's talking
let me give about my side let me give
you my side here's what's going to
happen okay
my thing's going to happen is the
following if kyrie
goes and gets vaccinated he's all about
getting attention
i don't know if this made sense no yeah
or he broke under the pressure no but
but no kyrie's historically been about
getting the attention such as oh i'm
really going through challenging time
emotionally because of what's going on
with the rights and protesting
okay and then you come and play in the
playoffs or you don't play in the
playoffs okay fine
if kyrie truly
stays
to his uh core and doesn't do anything
about it he's a true believer that it's
that simple okay so he's either gonna be
like yeah okay fine i'll do it money
whatever i'll go into after a lot of
thought with my family we've decided i'm
going to get the vaccine here's what i'm
going to do great there's a big
difference between a true believer and
somebody that needs attention and we
know attention is attention i mean roger
stone says there's no bad publicity
right you always want to get it so we're
going to find that out yes once and for
all yeah we're going to find that out
this is probably the biggest i think i
think i think if if i'm kyrie's advisor
if i'm kyrie's advisor i sit down and i
say listen let's turn off the cameras
it's you and i bro i'm not on the camera
nobody knows who i am i don't need the
attention i'm your guy we're talking he
says yeah
i said
what do you want to do
really talk to my mom talk i totally get
it man and you truly believe this fully
believe this yes
why don't you take a year off
take a year off you know what a year
off's going to do to him nothing
he has money he can handle a year off
you don't think a year from now people
are not going to want to sign a kyrie
irving when he's a free agent i think
they are i think you're from he's still
going to have a job if and in the next
12 months what could happen the next 12
months here's what could happen next 12
months in the next 12 months a lot can
change i mean a lot of stuff can change
market can change politics can change we
have new problems new crisis how quickly
do we go from talking about russia how
quickly did russia get turned off
overnight right how quickly does an
event that take place that we thought it
was the end of the world get turned off
overnight and we go to the next news
story right new cycle yeah okay whatever
so i think if he really wants he can
afford to take a year off take the
season off you're totally fine bro hey
for personal family reasons i've decided
to take the season off here next you
keep the money whatever it is and let me
see what i'm going to do next year
totally fine i think if he did that and
it's coming from a real reasonable place
i agree with you i think the one year
would be the right position to take and
in regards to what you're saying with
his teammates having a conversation i
can guarantee you durant at the
conversation with them i can't guarantee
your heart has had the conversation with
him i can guarantee you harden had the
conversation with him
i don't think nash had the conversation
with him i don't think nash is a pusher
i don't think nash is like no not like
that i don't like i don't think nash is
a pop i don't think nash is a meaning he
just wanted to understand he's probably
going to come more from that standpoint
john marks the gm
i think he had the conversation no for a
fact he had a conversation so we're
going to see what's going to happen by
the way hey it's a story we'll see
what'll take place but
you know again i think it's the new
colin kaepernick they're just treating
them slightly different than colin was
treated colin was a hero
uh kyrie's a villain for the record i
would take the vaccine for 200 million
dollars of course you will okay you
wouldn't and fyi for 200 million you
wouldn't take the vaccine
i can't phil heath i can't we hold these
two hundreds of self-evidence
let me say this real quick
wait a minute let me say this real quick
you're saying stop
if you know your own
blood work and gene variance and all
these other things if and if you fall
into the category of like hey if you
take this okay these are the side
effects that actually could be
exacerbated by your pre-existing
conditions and may put you in a bad
situation
that's where i'm at
because i've done you have health
concerns with it i have health proof
okay because i've done the research i've
done the work i mean hell i'm seven
times you got a challenge that happens
yeah so it's a personal story
because i along with everybody else
should be more
informed of their own body in their own
blood work and meet with certain doctors
so then they can make an informed choice
for me i did that i took it upon myself
to go do that my parents they got the
vacs
smart
my mom is she'll be
71 this year my stepfather my my father
had passed seven years ago but my
stepfather is 88
and he's had two lung surgeries so of
course he's going to take this you know
so i mean and i'm not like oh man you
guys are stupid no this is your choice
there's people that have taken a vaccine
right now that are willing to go say i
never took the vaccine to take the
vaccine again to get that 200 million
yeah i just want to let you know
i wish we were doing this podcast and
you know 1775 so i can hear you defend
the british empire man i i i wish the
things that there's nothing there's
nothing wrong with what
so what you've got to put a soldier in
your house what's the big deal look at
what the british did you do without 30
bucks bro for 200 million you're gonna
get on your high horse and be like i
would never i would never i'd rather die
on my sword on the hill than two hundred
dollars i love you like a brother shut
the [ __ ] up you're out of your [ __ ]
are you kidding me you're literally 200
million dollars out of my mind okay
forget the 200 million dollars right
no no i'm not going to forget the door
you think the nurses should get it and
get to keep their job i'm not talking
about the nurses i'm talking about kyrie
irving what the [ __ ] is different
talking about you it's not a matter of
skill said that you wouldn't get this
out of different fights don't you
realize that that plays into maybe an
agenda that we don't know about you
what you're saying about what you're
saying is that your morality is for sale
it's about 200 50 grand big bold letters
for 200 million dollars yes i am for
sale all right we're gonna play that
game later after after this is over what
else should you do for 200 million i
mean i would definitely get the vaccine
he'd get double penetrated right because
you need two of them to get vaccinated
this is wrong this is the short clip
david adam gets double penetrated for
200 million you said you would get
and do naughty things around men naked
for 10 grand i'd do that for free
boom there it is put that on the street
let's continue again let's continue for
free a bunch of men okay all right let's
continue to next story so you you so i'm
giving you the benefit of the doubt i'm
gonna go two stories back to back with
you you were bragging about how you've
been listened to dwayne johnson's new
song on repeat for 24 hours so dj is now
apparently a rapper and he said some
stuff about politics i want to read both
of the stories and both of them have to
do with uh dwayne johnson kyle you do
what you need to do with it so let's go
through it so page three
uh and by the way we all watch the video
you've seen the song right i'm assuming
you've listened to the song uh phil did
we watch it together yeah we watch it
together we watch it together so the
truth about dwayne johnson's rap debut
nikki swift story on october 8 tech nine
release its new single face off
featuring
joey cool king iso and dwayne johnson
for the latter in particular this was an
exciting experience made my historic rap
debut thankfully i didn't suck johnson
tweeted one day of the song's release i
never had the ambition to be an uh to be
a hip-hop artist or rapper but i did see
an opportunity here to create a song
that really inspired and motivated me to
push for more and fight for more i've
always loved music i love hip-hop and
blues and outlaws outlaw country music
and johnson's newly launched rep rap
career isn't motivated by money or fame
though that's not the important thing
the thing that gets my attention these
days and gets me out of bed have have to
do
uh have to be the things that i
absolutely love and i'm absolutely
passionate and by the way i believe in
this guy's worth you know what nearly
half a billion dollars you think he's
trying to become famous he's the most
famous guy in the world the guy's saying
if he needs a little bit more fame and
then i'll pause there before i go to the
next story with them uh and adam i'm
gonna come to you since you really had
some thoughts on this what do you think
about this new song were you impressed i
think we all have thoughts on it uh
real quick i'll go around round table
then i'll give my point do you think his
song was good
i think he was good the fact that he was
able to team up with someone who he's
been a fan of for a long time with tech9
because i remember chatting with him and
he always mentioned him so i think
what's cool about dwayne is that he's
always able to collaborate and okay you
know he has that juice so the
collaboration you like
the collaboration hey
it's uh it's like the song it's
definitely something where i'm like well
i'm not i'm not like i'll give it like a
seven five eight really you know no
because i mean there's still a
collaboration with it i'm not gonna say
it totally sucked i'm gonna say that
uh
is he shaquille o'neal no just say you
like the song is he killing no i'm
as long as dj produces this documentary
5.5
i love wrestling though i'm a wrestling
mark bro this bro this brought me back
in the day man i used to listen to the
macho man back in the day
[Music]
like a monkey oh yeah like i love that
stuff did you
what did you like it
um all right well i'll make two
different points here well maybe three i
thought the song was [ __ ] horrible
okay it wasn't i'll come out and say i
thought it was bad i think tech nine is
non-existent if you name the top hundred
rappers all right tech nine would not be
in the equation
red nation style i i don't like if you
said i'm sorry i'm serious if you said
the top 100 rappers in the world tech 9
wouldn't be on the list all right guys
maybe people in the comments need to
correct your house because i'm telling
you right now
what technique is 50 something years old
and how old is and how it is snoop how
you're putting words in my mouth what
i'm saying is is that this is a guy who
has been i don't want to get into a
fight today i think he's itching for
something no i didn't have three cups of
coffee well maybe that's why but i mean
you anyone out there if you if you see
these guys in person what's your second
generation what's your second point
what's your second point okay so i'll
give him his credit i'll give him credit
and this maybe will help the audience a
little bit
his last point
uh i love hip hop and blues and outlaw
country music uh this is not motivated
by money or fame that's not the
important thing the things that get my
attention these days get me that get me
out of bed have to be the things that
absolutely love and are passionate yeah
i love that part because
i thought the song was not good at all
not even i wouldn't listen to it if it
was do i don't care if it's tech nine
rock dwayne whatever it's not that good
of a song however what i do appreciate
and this is what other people can get
out of this is
your comfort zone will kill you
get out of your comfort zone he said
he's not a rapper but he wanted to do
this cool powerful we all do things
that you second guess i don't i don't
know it's not really for me i don't know
if whether it's rap whether it's you
know bodybuild whether it's start a
business whatever it is at some point
you're you're going to doubt yourself
yeah at some point you're going to say i
don't i'm not rapper i give him props
because and the fact that he went out
there and did that absolutely i respect
that you have to get out of your comfort
zone this is also going to kill you this
is what i'm happy that a celebrity isn't
out there bitching moaning or lecturing
me this is what rich people should do
right like you want to you want to go
out there and sing sing you want to get
get in a music video get into music why
not dude live your dreams man like go
for it i don't think it was nearly as
bad and also i am unashamedly a rock fan
and i used to love watching monday night
raw when he would come out with his
guitar and he would sing about you know
he would sing about the the uh what was
it the the uh jabroni drive i'm just
down at the
jabroni drive it's the smackdown hotel
like i love the rock bro and look
my only thing if i could have given them
any not that i'm anybody to give them
any advice i think they took it a little
too seriously it could have been a
little more fun it could have been like
a little more on brand but look i only i
only ever criticize art when i feel like
i could have done better yeah i don't
think i could have done better i think
the rock he did what he could do i ain't
got adam you got bars oh i got bars
[ __ ] drop a drop i freestyled you
yesterday i lost it
that [ __ ] was terrible and you're saying
that he and he sucked i'm not a rapper
but i got out but i got out of my
comfort zone
other than it being a tequila commercial
because because we did have his
did you like his song i'm probably not
going to listen to it ever again i will
tell you that i'm probably not going to
listen to it again but i i probably list
maybe it's because i've listened to
moana you're welcome one too many times
and i'm so addicted to that one because
that song when he sang that one that was
actually sick i think that's his genre i
don't know if i felt the hip-hop thing
with him but i think i think he's got a
voice i think if he wants to do
something he can do something whatever
you see pbd no drop this video the day
that happens i it's just you know what
you know what i like in this deal real
talk tell me him rapping getting out
there putting himself out there is
pbd getting out there and doing some
stand-up comments yeah that guy i feel
like that could happen yeah i think i
think that's eventually gonna happen but
you know yesterday there was an
interview i watched with him that he put
on his uh instagram account
and he says can i curse on this can i
curse on this he says yeah you can't so
he started talking he said so tell me
you know what is the thing about being a
celebrity and he explains what it is to
be a celebrity he says what's the
toughest thing about being a celebrity
he said i will never complain about
being a celebrity this thing's changed
my life i have nothing to have no right
to complain i love
the attitude man i love that attitude i
love a guy that goes to his agent when
he's a just a wrestler and he says i
want to be will smith but better i love
a guy that's got a vision for himself
and he's so obsessed and determined to
go out there and win i love that part of
rock i fully love that part of rock and
uh i think he's at a point right now
that anything he touches who won here
tech nine or rock behind no tech nine
one here because oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
you got more visibility
now let me go to the other story let me
go to the other story which is uh page
six if you want to go to where he was
being interviewed and talked about
politics i got him in my phone here's
just here's what was brought up so
dwayne johnson admits how do you hear
that dwayne johnson admits he doesn't
know the first thing about politics
while teasing the possible 2024 white
house run while dwayne johnson is not
ruling out a presidential run the future
he also admitted his own shortcomings
stating that he doesn't know the first
thing about politics you know at the end
of the day i don't know the first thing
about politics i don't know the first
thing about policy i care deeply about
our country i care about every
african-american who believes red and
that's that's all that's all of them and
there's no delusion here i may have some
decent leadership qualities but that
doesn't necessarily make me a great
presidential candidate that's where i am
today fantastic uh comment to make about
it and to be honest about it however i
will say uh there is no way in the world
rock doesn't know anything about
politics he is in to he made it to the
top of two of the most political
industries in the world
uh wrestling hardcore is political when
he first came out he says i'm not he
said he says i'm not gonna be the bad
guy i'm not gonna be the bad and the
wrestler that's the enemy i'm not gonna
be that guy i'm going to be the good guy
the hero the loved one he made that
decision that's the role i want to play
right in hollywood how political is it
and he comes in a guy that's as big as
he is and the last guy that made it in
hollywood was who that size is arnold
arnold would have made it happen and
this guy goes and makes it happen so yes
he's been in politics for the last 25
years he has more experience in politics
than 99 of political candidates
to undermine that part of it the guy
knows how to play the game sitting there
with big agents and billionaires
negotiating contracts and deals and zoa
and xfl and all this other stuff he's
fully qualified to want to do it now the
area that i do agree with him is he
probably needs
a year of sitting there with people
asking him questions to see what his
real answer is going to be and doing a
ton of research read this book read this
article watch this documentary go
through this watch this debate look how
this guy handled look how reagan handled
it look how obama handled it look at the
mistake here was made by rick perry look
at the mistake he was it was made by
this person and in that part he's he he
needs help in that because it is another
game he needs to go hire the aaron
spicer of
and he can he oh and then
and i think that's yeah of course it
goes to show that it is about running
mates as you talk aboutly he's always
had a great team you know his team with
danny garcia and tgc and all that stuff
shout out to them but overall i mean
he's always been able to really win
you look at some of the films like he'll
make fun of some of his own films that
didn't gross better than some of the
other ones is there anybody more
likeable
is there any star more like
any superstar more likeable than him i
don't think so the only guy i think that
there's only really two that are even
closer and i would say i'd say chris
pratt and kevin and uh downey jr not
kevin mcconaughey no no kind of hey
maybe yeah maybe he's close robert
downey jr very very likable josh brolin
but they're not the size of the star
that he is no none of those guys are
anywhere but it comes down to
ryan reynolds is incredibly likable yeah
uh well at least this is their
personalities i don't know them but i
mean i'm talking about i'm talking tom
cruise level rock level
brad pitt level
leonardo dicaprio level i'm talking that
level i'm talking kim kardashian level
i'm talking anybody liked more than this
guy i would say maybe chris pratt
christopher i don't know
anywhere in here
but what i will say is i mean we we all
know that this is a man of great
discipline and hard work he talks about
all the time but he actually does it and
he's not afraid of a challenge so i
think
to your point he's going to do the work
he's probably already been doing it he's
always the hardest working in the room
as he says but also like you got to
think when he's been doing prior to
kovit movie after movie after movie
after movie business after business
his capacity is what i look at most when
you're talking about being in politics
because
he's if he is starting out
at you know let's say the seasoned
veterans the career politicians are up
here and he's like right down here he's
gonna make sure
that he's up here
very very quick to be competitive and i
think that's what's gonna separate him
from other people and he's gonna make
people watch because they're going to
see
i trust that he's going to be extremely
competitive with whatever he does and we
don't know we just have to wait and see
but a great point i trust that he's
going to be extremely competitive
and he would push other people i would
fully agree
he'd have to i have one issue with it
everything else he's doing that's really
good
he shouldn't do it yeah let me make one
quick point
three p's that come to mind the politics
you said he's been doing politics for a
couple decades now the persona no doubt
whatsoever likable gregarious name
recognition above all
the the thing at question that you're
talking about is the policy does he
actually know
policy i think he does does he actually
understand ramifications of saying
things does he actually understand
things i mean we don't talk about many
if we sound bites that he's done wrong
or anything because he's been well
groomed and he knows who he is so i
think when you know who you are you can
actually speak from the heart and that's
what he does pretty well i give him mad
props for that and he's unafraid to say
that hey
i'm some of a layman to this subject but
i know who i am and i'm probably going
to be able to do what pat recruit
recruit the best people to ensure that
he wins i think he's afraid though that
that's i i do think he is afraid and i
think that he's afraid of one thing
here's what he's afraid of uh
he's a he's afraid of
he's so liked that i think a part of him
is afraid of not being liked
okay i i think he will be afraid of
losing fans
and and and it it is so important to him
to be loved you know the five love
languages go through all of it i think
it matters to him so much to be loved
that's a great point i i don't think he
i think he understands how to deal with
authority i think he knows how to manage
authority and it's very uh kudos to him
because for your entire life you're
going to have to learn how to manage if
you don't know how to deal with
authority you're not going to make it to
the top right there isn't you know this
whole thing about rebel against
authority i'm sorry good luck to you you
have to know how to work with them you
have to know how to work with authority
this doesn't mean sitting there this
doesn't mean sitting there and bowing
down but it means you have to understand
the power positions if you don't
understand that concept good luck to you
you have a limit to where you're going
to hit he understands playing the power
players dealing with the bosses dealing
with the money people dealing with the
director's kudos to him
but i think he's so concerned about
being like that i don't think
politically he's going to go on the side
that's truly him let me politically let
me finish okay i think politically he's
going to go to a side
that's gonna please
the last industry he was a part of and i
think it's gonna backfire then he should
talk to andrew yang and he should talk
to tulsa yeah but if that's the case
then he needs to talk to them and
because you know i just talked to you
about andrew yang was on sam harris very
very very open and honest about how yeah
how bad it was being a part of the dnc
so there was a big difference between
running for mayor versus running for
office yeah very different because he
was a lead dog and lost but he was
nobody and he garnered some attention i
watched the whole thing about yeah it's
very interesting right so the um
now you said there was three p's right
there was what was it politics
policy all right i'm sure there's some
other people had a fourth p yeah and
that's uh prophecy because the the
movie idiocracy has
the downfall
of the corporate states of america when
a wrestler named dwayne takes over as
president so we can fulfill the prophecy
again for that to happen he somebody has
to tell him you're gonna go from the
most liked guy to the most hated guy and
it's going to happen how many decisions
has he made though
fyi here's the other part with him
here's the other part with him
so
think about
what andrew's trying to do new party the
forward party and the whole thing he was
talking about was katherine gayle which
i've interviewed them and katherine
gayle launched her book on valuetainment
with michael porter is that right wow
yeah kathryn gilmar kai you remember
that interview that we did and this
whole point system where first place it
doesn't help you to be bashing everybody
because you're going to drop that whole
point system that we're talking about if
you get fifth place votes you know it
works out it's a very interesting
concept that they're talking about okay
uh but can this guy really lead a new
party no andrew yank no he can't carry
that can the brilliant but i don't think
he's charismatic i think yank is a great
number three or a number four he's not a
two or one i don't think that can be
ryan the rock i don't think that would
be very powerful i don't think yank is a
number one i don't think yank is the
number one there's there's difference to
number ones i think rock is a good
number one but the rock
if he really wanted to do it the right
way and he really wanted to be a
synergist and he really wanted to bring
both sides closer to each other here's
how you do it when my parents got a
divorce
and they were going through it both
sides wanted to win me over
it's kind of like hey you know i'm this
i'm this i'm that i said said mom listen
you're my mom i love you but please
don't talk bad about that i don't like
it and i told the family if you guys
talk about my dad i don't need to see
you because i love my dad more than i
love you guys it's that simple then i
went to my dad's side and my dad's i was
talking [ __ ] about my mom i said he's a
borosian the armenians would say he's a
bad david he's an assyrian my armenians
would say
he's a the other one would say he's a
borosi and he's armenian they would play
that game and i told my mom's family i
said listen i love my dad i love my mom
please don't talk trash it's just not
gonna fly
anyways eventually they realized this
guy's not messing around
we're in us i haven't seen my dad for
two and a half years a lady comes to our
house it's me my mom and my sister and
she says
gabriel wants to see his kids
and he wants to know if you guys are
going to let him see see his kids and my
mom says so what do you guys want to do
i said i want to see my dad absolutely
you don't even know how tough of a
decision that was because my life sucked
for about six months after saying that
so i said i won't see my dad you want to
see your dad i want to see my dad
so my dad comes and picks me up at
virgil's and we go and spend the sunday
together how long have it been since
you've seen him two and a half years my
dad's my best friend my you know you
guys when i feel about my dad so i said
i want to see my dad so i go and spend a
whole day and a half of my dad he picks
me up and we have good conversations
together i told him stuff i didn't like
his all this other i'm 12 years old 12
and a half years old but both sides
got a glimpse of listen
it's family it's everybody coming
together
that's it or i'm not compromising
and that became a backbone to the family
to realize this guy's not going to
compromise my entire life that's been my
mo okay
if the rock wants to be a synergist and
wants to bring america together and
wants to be a hero where you're
remembered a thousand years from now 500
years from now where you become the
first guy that saves the democracy on
average the democracy doesn't last past
250 years and we're at 246 years right
now give her 245 years whatever the
timeline is 1776
if he comes and he says i'm running as
an independent and he says these are the
things i disagree on the right but these
are the things i like on the right i'm a
pro military guy because here's what the
military's done for me i'm a pro uh
police guy here's here's what i don't
agree with the left but i tell you one
thing i work with a lot of people in the
lgbtq community these are some of the
nicest people i've ever dealt with
here's what i disagree but i've dealt
with he says i'd like to bring america
together and this is why i'm running as
independent if he does that let me tell
you
he
could win and he ain't know the guy that
got 21 19
uh uh running against senior which
senior doesn't comment about one guy and
you know what i'm talking about
senior in his documentary at the end
when they did the last thing there's one
person in the interview he wouldn't talk
about does it cost he said i don't want
to talk about ross pearl i don't want to
talk about him i don't want to talk
about you have to see on his eyes he
gets upset when ross pro's conversation
the name comes up this ain't ross pro
bro this is dwayne johnson yeah dwayne
could win as an independent he'll go
into history books as one of the
greatest synergists at the greatest time
in america but here's the thing i'll
give you a
five percent chance he does it because
he's too much about being liked and a
part of being independent people are not
gonna lie do you think the the
quote-unquote deep state would let
something like that happen you think the
you think our our military-industrial
complex would let something like okay so
this is the part where i'm gonna remind
you of something that you you believe in
and you gotta go to your core with that
i believe the people are more powerful
than they know
and i still believe people are more
powerful than they know
the the the first thing that goes is
faith we talked about this on the last
podcast there are a lot of people of
faith that are very necessary whether
you believe in god whether you like
christianity catholicism mormonism you
know jehovah seven day whether you like
or agree with any of that stuff or not
here's what you desperately need you
desperately need a big percentage of
america to have faith you desperately
need that that grandma that has that
faith in his grandson when the mother
doesn't believe in the grandma says
listen be patient with your son i was
patient with you this kid is a special
kid he's going places i'm telling you i
have faith in him be patient with him
that grandma with that faith is what
makes that mother's relationship and the
father's relationship be better with the
son thank god for the christians and the
god-fearing god-loving people in america
whoever whatever faith you practice
judaism i don't care what it is whatever
you practice the people who have faith
in something
they're going to be able to pull
something like this off so whether the
deep state wants to get in the way and
they don't want to do anything about it
the deep state couldn't stop trump and
trump is not as big as uh uh iraq
there's no way trump and uh derock are
in the same league go back to 2014 and
look at some of trump's tweets when he
would tweet 324 likes 317 likes 428
likes this is a guy that became
president he was only getting 3 400
likes seven years ago to go look at
trump's uh dwayne johnson's tweet go
look at dwayne johnson's instrument
they're saying the same you're talking
about potentially the biggest
personality ever to run i just hope he
gets the right people on his side that
can have this conversation that i just
had with him because i'm convinced
this guy can go in the history books
as the greatest center just this
country's ever had i'm fully convinced
dvd i don't think he'll do it since
we've been talking the p's
dvd yeah
prediction time p
do you think he runs
what party does he run with and does he
have your vote go ahead phil with a p
like you think he runs i think he runs
as an independent okay um
i really want to see a debate
because
i do believe
that if he's doing exactly what pat's
saying
and just going all out
first of all the ratings would go
through the roof can you imagine his
political commercials it would just be
[ __ ] amazing so he has your vote oh
man depending on the policies absolutely
okay absolutely depending on the policy
i'm a policy guy you're a policy guy i
don't i don't think 2024 uh i i think if
he's talking about it now i mean how
many years did trump talk about it
before he actually wrote 20 years 20
years maybe even longer yeah 85 yeah you
know i i think that
the fact that this is a 24 look this is
a 25 hour gig he likes to work out three
hours a day he's not gonna be able to do
that he's not gonna be able to turn off
from the world and get three hours of a
workout in there's gonna be a crisis
every moment of every second uh he's
gonna have people that are that are
constantly coming after him um
he's like pat said very astutely he's
used to being liked right now and then
you think the rock how do you think the
rock is going to handle you know crazed
activists running after him in the
bathroom with a cell phone camera how do
you think that you don't think he's
running i think he might run get a taste
of it and be like what the what was i
thinking i i had the greatest life on
earth why the hell would i do that i
think i think i think the the one person
that can give him the best advice and if
i'm part of his strategy team here's
what i would be doing i think the best
person i can give him the best advice is
donald trump
and but he can't ask trump he can't have
a meeting with remember the video he did
about trump where is he okay here's what
i mean by this i think somebody on his
camp
needs to who is connected with a sean
hannity or is connected to a
whoever that's going to potentially do
an interview with trump and trump's
going to take the interview has to ask
the questions that rock really wants to
be asked and here's the questions the
questions that rock really needs wants
to be asked is hey going back let me ask
you had a great life was it was it worth
it to get the last checklist check on
checklist you know done which is what
you can forever say you were billionaire
you partied you did this you did that tv
show 15 years apprentice and president
was it worth getting the last check mark
of being a president i think someone
needs to have that conversation and rock
wants that conversation with trump to
see if trump will say it wasn't worth it
or it was worth it because that's the
thing he has to ask himself i think he's
going to run and i think he's going to
run on the left i don't think he's going
to run on the right i think does he have
your vote
no he does not because really no he runs
as an independent i would consider his
policies he runs on the left i think
he's just been bought and you know china
the movies he's doing with china and how
careful they are with china and all that
stuff you have to know where i'm at with
china i mean you i don't need to remind
you what i'm with china so i think if he
takes a stand against china i think if
he takes a stand against both sides both
sides he says look both sides have come
up to me and told me that i should run
as a republican and i should run as a
democrat and i got to tell you i just
relate to both sides and i disagree part
of both sides i think i'm independent
and if you get behind me hey let's make
it work i think he could win as an
independent but i'm telling you five
percent chance he does a 95 percent
chance he won't do it he runs at 11. and
i know you want to move on but what does
that say on a deeper level what does
that say about our political system the
type of government that we have right
now that
somebody that we all agree would have a
great chance of winning wouldn't want to
put himself through what it would take
to win all it tells you is does that
mean that that we're missing out on our
great leaders because those people are
we always have to not run yeah but all
it tells you is all it tells you is that
he uh uh one you're scared and two it's
not a true statesman what's a statesman
what's the difference between politician
and a statesman go to a statesman what's
a statesman about what's a politician
about they're wired in a different way
it's it's not the same wiring you know
mansion is a statesman you know some of
the guys on the right that disagree with
trump they're statesmen you have to like
tucker going up there and
disagreeing with what trump was doing
how many times have you seen tucker
interview trump why do you think i don't
know people realize this trump is not a
big fan of tucker how many times have
you seen trump interview with hannity i
never watch it you know and if i watch
it i watch it because we're talking
about it on the podcast because to to
hannah these eyes trump can't do no
wrong cheerleader so it's not it's
so i think
i think true statesmen today
uh uh are are tough to come by but if
somebody truly wants to make history
instead of getting the check mark
i think you got to study the greatest
statement in the history of america and
see what they went through what was
their formula how did they think why did
they do what they did it's a little bit
more about what you were talking about
earlier on dying on the sword and all
that stuff a true state statesman is
country over your
policies it's not policies country over
your politics country over you being
liked and you don't find a lot of people
like that too who would you even put as
the top statesman in america today
today today who's up there you said joe
manchin okay he's on the list is is bill
maher on that list is joe rogan on the
list does it have to be a politician who
in politics is a true statement a
statesman who is a synergist who's not a
divider who do you actually put on that
list today i know that you're a big fan
of tulsi gabbard is she is a true
statesman states woman who who actually
is on that list justin amish tom massey
uh i'd give it to rand paul
um
mansion
for sure
uh
who's the guy from south dakota those
are all people that
uh uh uh south dakota no
wyoming you're talking about carolina
south carolina lindsey graham not
lindsey graham no no no no tim uh tim
scott maybe i'm not even saying the
state right the guy that we had on we uh
jose interviewed him what's uh uh oh
you're like trey gowdy trey gowdy yeah
i think trey gowdy's american yeah i
think i think i think well who that
actually could win how about that
because none of those names are going to
win anything other than maybe mansion
something which one of somebody that
could win could win
why could tulsi gabbard not win okay
maybe she could win but she'd uh
against recognition
name recognition tulsi needs a little
bit uh
i feel toasty needs to do one more thing
to add to her fame and you know like she
needs a show she needs a
something i don't know what it is like
she needs something to go so this this
is the massive this is the massive
problem with our system you are
convinced
aoc is going to be president united
states one day
but i'm sitting here you're gonna take
it and i'm gonna well you do 20 20. so
20 chance do you give tulsi gabbard a 20
chance of being president united states
uh i'll tell you right now a veteran a
sitting senator an eloquent speaker if
it weren't for public persona and
popularity contest yes she's
unfortunately she's way better than ever
she's got 1.1 million followers on
twitter unfortunately
and aoc has 13 million followers on
twitter so now let me go back to tnx 13x
so so roger stone number one is what
relevance constant relevance she's not
going to get relevance from mainstream
media because they're not even going to
give it to the spotlight they're just
not going to give it to you tell us so
what's she right here she needs to go
well she next time she's coming to
florida she's coming here so you got you
got what she's going to go on rogan
she's going to go on all this stuff all
these things she needs she needs another
pop i think she needs another pop like
you know trump pulled from where trump
from billionaire trump from wealthy
people trumpel from uh apprentice
trumple from new york trump from all the
after-parties he did trump pull from
golf trump from a lot of different
places right
rock's gonna pull from wrestling rock's
gonna pull from hollywood rock's gonna
pull from bodybuilding like i think
she's not multi-dimensional enough today
to pull that's the only thing i'm
thinking about and aside from that
somebody powerful needs to go and
back her up somebody needs to back her
up if that happens she doesn't need the
other part but somebody needs to do that
and and
i just i just don't know if that's
happening that's a very dangerous place
to be man because basically what you
guys are saying then is that the
mainstream media the
media apparatuses are the people who
introduce who has access and who doesn't
right aoc is on tv all the time because
they put her on tv all the time tulsi
gabbard speaks just as much does just as
many instagram lives they never make it
too late you're saying though so so what
i'm saying is is that essentially what
the people there's a very small
percentage of unelected people that run
corporate media that are giving people
enough access to be have a 20 chance as
opposed to that even news but but what
i'm saying it's not news but what it is
is horrible but it is dangerous it is
horrible popularity
but it is horrible it is horrible it's
not it's not organic but but i tell you
what my problem with this is so i i've
had the last week i've had calls we've
been
talking about potentially buying a big
paper okay and we've been having calls
and i've made the effort we've called we
we want to make an offer to them anyways
it's it's somebody everybody every one
of you guys knows who this is it's
massive you know who it is uh and we've
been going back and forth they're
playing the whole thing up well we're
not really interested right now because
we're doing so well and all this other
stuff right and we're not really
interested in doing something like that
right now okay because of xyz okay the
one newspaper in america actually making
money
uh uh no so so anyways but the the point
i'm making to you is
i'm doing this because it's a long-term
play okay
the people who oppose what is happening
with all the progressive policies today
in america when is the last time they
had an emergency meeting together that's
a three-day meeting sitting down saying
what the hell is your strategy when's
the last time somebody spearheaded that
to put a strategy in place when because
the left does it all the time when's the
last time the wright did it when's the
last time they got together and they
said let's get the biggest media guy
let's get a tulsi in here let's get a
rant in here let's get around in here
let's get all these guys in here what do
we need to do let's talk about a
strategy and somebody needs to be the
strategy somebody needs to be the
general manager to the head coach how
about we did this how about we did that
if that doesn't happen all this other
stuff is just a bunch of lip service so
you have to fight against mainstream
media they're not going away you got to
play your game you got a forbes magazine
that sells to china for 95 what are you
doing like how do you let a magazine
like that go away fortune is now left
money is now left inc is now left forbes
is now left what the hell are you doing
capitalism is about to be gone so what
are some so all of these small
opportunities that keep going away
capitalists should buy all these
magazines to keep this con concept of
capitalism going now you're hearing
socialism is not a bad approach in
forbes magazine you tell me how that
makes any sense it's like ayn rand
selling her paper and all of a sudden
they're talking about social is a good
idea that doesn't make any sense yeah
it's not really an article in forbes
yeah so they're talking about that yeah
so
the point the point is what's happening
these things can these things are
happening and there's not a strategy to
fight against what gerard is talking
about if you're not gonna have a
strategy in place i'm sorry you deserve
to get your ass handed i can't tell you
dude that that there's so many people
that feel helpless in the moment
specifically because of what you just
said that they
they feel like what's even the point
that this is an unwinnable battle like
this culture
i know what you're saying right but
there's like there's you're right
there's not that guy saying listen if
you disagree this is what you got to do
do this this this and this do that like
yeah i couldn't agree with you more man
i could not agree with your ppd even if
you're saying if the right did have a
strategy
and i'm not even being sarcastic would
it even matter because trump owns that
party no of course it would matter by
the way that's part of a strategy though
you have to know he is in the strategy
so somebody has to go and have a combo
with him
to talk to him that's part of the
strategy he's going to speak to him and
will he will listen to him the right
person can who who's trump listening
ever the right person is can and like
the right person
let's define the right property
what matters more to your country or
your brand country no no not to you to
trump somebody needs to have a
conversation with him that's actually a
legitimate question what matters more to
your country or your name that's the
question
i'd love to see hear his answer because
because a follow-up question after that
is what
here's what's a follow-up question so
you ask the question president
donald j trump what's more important to
you or your last name and your legacy or
your country what do you think he's
going to answer
what do you think he's going to answer i
think he's going to say everything that
he's built his legacy his brand i think
he's going to say his country i think
they're intertwined yeah yeah i think
he's gonna say his country then the
follow-up question is what perfect so if
the people in the party you're
representing
no longer think you're the person to
help save the country are you okay
voting for somebody that can get the job
done to save the country you care so
much about that's a great hypothetical
but he owns that party the the party
wants him i don't but what i'm have you
seen the latest results what i'm trying
to tell you is so what's the alternative
you don't have that meeting you don't
have that sit down you don't have that
conversation you don't have that
strategy session the right is going to
constantly sit on the sidelines and say
oh we can't do nothing about it oh
shucks eight more years oh it's you know
if he is the
so what are you saying that if he
shouldn't run that hey you're gonna we
need you to be a cheerleader for pence
or cheerleader for
somebody else or somebody who knows how
to deal with big egos who has no
aspirations to run needs to get in the
mix and have those conversations behind
closed doors and nobody needs to know
about those conversations yeah somebody
who is like a qualified guy who can who
can go have those conversations talk to
george soros
i hear you yeah loud and clear okay i
think he's had quote unquote adults in
the room whether that's general mattis
or general kelly or whether that's i
don't think mattis is the guy though
okay whoever it is but you know what
kind of a person in five years we
haven't identified the guy for five
years we've been saying well somebody
needs to talk to trump and you know talk
a little sense yeah and the only name
that has come up that people were like
okay maybe he'll listen is ivanka and
i'm pretty sure she and jared kushner
are done with politics they're having a
nice little life down in south beach
building a house
they're not you think kushner is going
back into the white house no way they're
done with politics no i don't know about
it there's no way they're done with
politics okay other than her who else
does he actually listen to a legitimate
question so to do to think a person like
that doesn't exist is a form of giving
up right to think a person like that
doesn't exist it's a form of saying
there's nothing i can do but i feel
helpless [ __ ] i don't come from the
helpless community to to think that
there's nothing we can do about it no
the the conversation and the approach
matters if if you don't know how to
approach somebody based with their
personality the right way you're not
going to get results okay it's all on
the approach so if you go and say matter
style dude who the hell are you talking
to me like this what do you it's got to
be the right person with zero threat
with zero everything is safe protected
all of that just have that conversation
with the agenda of america first
and those are his words but essentially
it comes down to like what we were
talking about i believe a couple months
ago with pat
pat saying like on twitter he's changing
his uh handle to a synergist
i think that person needs to rise up and
actually have that conversation for that
to even come into fruition and we
obviously don't know who that is i think
it would be a hell of a fight um and i
you know i think
but what is that conversation is what
i'm trying to i'm not a politician i
have no freaking clue and i haven't met
trump nor do i understand his
persona we only know so much right but
we do know this you didn't win
at the end of the day you didn't win
and you got to be able to figure out a
new strategy and recognize i mean look
like i think we all can agree like
during those debates there were certain
points in time where it's like
uh even if i was
rooting for you you're like man
that wasn't smart
you have to look at game film
at the end of the and you have to be
honest about it you have to raise your
hand and say yeah that wasn't smart and
i think if we're talking about
vulnerability i think we live in a world
where you know people don't want to
raise their hand and say yeah i i [ __ ]
up and i shouldn't have said that this
is but this is what i was really trying
to convey then maybe other people listen
and again it's not about pulling people
from the 42 percent of the 44 percent
it's that you know 10 to 15
right do you want to talk about that
frank lunt story or yeah i'm going to
that right away it's funny you just said
that so frank luntz if you want to go to
page six donald trump will never be
president again says renowned poster
frank luntz this is a sydney morning
herald won the most one of the world's
top holsters frank luntz who has advised
multiple republican presidents says
donald trump will never never again lead
the united states he will not win if
trump wins again he will be nominated by
the republicans but he will never be
elected president because there are too
many people who hate him is what he says
and he continues saying trump is the
most popular republican by far but he
can't win a general election because in
the end politics is about persona as
much as it is about policy and his
persona is unacceptable to too many
people once has worked as a strategist
and poster for the republican party for
almost 30 years and is regarded as one
of the world's most
incisive commentators so you obviously
agree with that right you don't think
you'll ever win
i think number one this guy do you know
who frank luntz is you want to pull him
up you've seen his face before
he
he this is what he does
like and he's uh he works for the
republican party i want to say he might
say he's independent but this is what he
does
i think it's a case of
if it were trump versus biden again and
again i don't even think biden should
run in four years it's almost like
unacceptable
versus unaware
there's 40 60 of the country that thinks
trump is on unacceptable
i do not accept him
there's a large contingency in the
country that thinks biden is just
completely
helpless and unaware so this goes back
to my initial point
of are these our two best options is
this really where we're at right now can
we get a tulsi gabbard in there can we
get a desantis in there can we get a
rock in there is this really where we're
at that we're deciding again between
donald trump unacceptable versus biden
unaware that's what i'm saying right
now as an independent today and the
climate is perfect for the rock to win
as an independent i agree if if it's
biden
trump on the left on the right and then
you got rock coming up the middle
i would vote for rock in a heartbeat
regardless of policy
because what we've established is that a
lot of it is just persona and therefore
it's policy versus persona in this
scenario
where
you just explained it perfect i mean you
know you may not have the policies
initially as far as like the rock is
concerned but he has the persona that
oversees this like and people did not
vote for trump
enough because not because of the
policies it was because of the persona i
agreed so you know i
i got
you got nothing no i was just saying him
it could have been from 2015. i heard
the same crap leading up the hillary was
going to win in a landslide and
listen i didn't vote for trump in uh 16
right and but all i heard everywhere was
this guy's got no chance the polls are
he's down by nine percent he's down by
12 there's only three months to go but
there was something in the eye test that
everywhere i looked i didn't see a
single hillary lawn sign i didn't see a
single hillary banner i just saw trump
everywhere i was like this is odd
something about what i'm seeing day to
day driving around is different than
what i'm hearing on the news and every
pollster in the world came out and said
afterwards right 538 we need to readjust
our polls we didn't take this into
account we didn't take that in account
and then people want to act like he got
smoked in this last election he got more
votes he's the first president in the
history of the united states to get more
votes in his re-election campaign and
lose do you feel that some people now
are realizing that policies
are important
yeah because of what is currently going
on in the world i think to a certain
degree that's a good point phil i also
think that
i don't want him to run because he
activates the other side too much i
think desantis or somebody else they
don't have the vitriol that's gonna
activate that extra five six percent i
think trump is going to activate people
that right now are completely
disenfranchised that are frankly
embarrassed that they supported biden i
know a lot of people that are
embarrassed that they they were like you
know what man orange man bad but maybe
it wasn't this bad my god right so many
people like that but i will i believe
you don't i i will say that you do bring
up a couple of valid points and i and i
we you even addressed this on rogan i
don't think that many people were voting
because they loved biden
it's because trump was that unacceptable
and you said the debated the other side
and voted and that well
um
people voted against trump not for biden
but
you said in 20 the difference between
2016 and 2020
is that he was an unproven commodity at
that point i don't know this guy donald
trump he's kind of in there i don't know
he's yeah he's crazy he's doing some
things i'll give him the benefit of the
doubt you know he'll shake up washington
by 2020 people knew exactly what they
were getting and they're like i've seen
this movie before
i know how this ends i do not want to
see the same movie for the fifth
freaking time i'm good let's see a new
movie even if the new movie sucks i've
seen that movie too many times i know
how it is so the pendulum now is on
policy probably no matter what i mean
i've chatted with a lot of different
people
um
black white everything and they've all
said that
policy is more important because of the
current economic climate and i think you
take the name plates off of candidates
yeah i think we're going to realize that
we live in a world where man this person
has a great persona but these policies
are great however yeah with show with
social media and all that stuff you've
got to have both brother you've got to
tell yourself what percentage of
americans actually vote based on policy
and policies alone but when you're
looking at 20 percent so what are the
points right now
small when you say policy that's let's
just define most most voters vote on one
issue single issue voters make up over
70 votes so
there's no and it's not even necessarily
possible whatever benefits them yeah
right
and single issue is what benefits them
yeah no it is but kai go ahead you were
trying to say something
kai we can't hear you i can okay now go
ahead uh for me a big thing as well as
we talked about with trump if the market
wouldn't have crashed what are the odds
that he would have been re-elected now
can that can they sustain that and push
that out for another two years if the
market crashes what are the odds biden
can get elected you're talking about
covet not in a market crash no marketing
no the market crash was due to covet
it's what you're saying yeah what i'm
saying is yeah also that the the the
fact that that's now bounced back in 13
months
seems to be a little bit propagated and
not well let me full mark let me let me
go into the goldman sachs story and
what's going on at the port of la story
i think that kind of has to do with what
you're talking about so goldman sachs
gets even groomier on the u.s economy
cnn goldman sachs is becoming
increasingly pessimistic about the u.s
economy as chronovirus support from the
government phases out and consumer
spending remains on an uncertain path
over the weekend the wall street bank
downgraded its forecast for america's
economic growth which is closely
monitored by the investment community
goldman sachs now expects
the economy to expand 5.6 this year
compared to a previous 5.7 estimate in
2022 uh 5.7 in 2022 growth is projected
to expand
four percent down from 4.4 it is the
second time goldman sachs has revised
its 2021 forecast lower in two months
goldman sachs also thinks spending could
decline as people could continue to work
from home encouraging them to prepare
their own lunches instead of popping
into a local restaurant so that's
goldman okay that's what gold now you're
laughing you have a comment you have
thoughts yeah i just it's so obvious
this and even it's coming from cnn but
this is this is how media works the
headline
like if you actually look at the numbers
you want to talk persona versus policy
goldman sachs predicts an even gloomier
look on the outcome goldman sachs has
predicted 5.6
down from 5.7 oh my god point one that's
not a big number what are we talking
about here's the question
it would your point would make sense if
it said fox news instead of cnn why cnn
telling this story
headlines
again i don't know i'm not even worried
about cnn i don't agree right 5.7 was
glued down from the 6.2 yeah so that's
5.6.2 yeah so well this is 4.4
to 4 that's 10 that's a real number so
that part's a real number it's like 11
you're talking about with a number like
that so look they're not optimistic
about the economy so what happens if the
economy takes a hit the next 12 18 24
months does mid years take a massive hit
for the left midterms midterms
oh i i don't think that i give the
probably 80 chance republicans take
control of the house or win the midterms
for sure i mean that's that's not even
the current climate that's just politics
in general the
the party that's not in power takes over
them
in the midterms that i mean you probably
have a very clear example of this but i
think republicans will take over in the
midterms
yeah uh well look man
who knows the um
there's so much there's so much
redlining there's so much gerrymandering
that there's there's so much happening
behind the scenes that i don't i don't
want to get too in-depth on people but i
mean look 20 we talk about uh we talk
about the
um what was the recall election in
california we talked about that a lot
right something that we didn't really
discuss in depth was the demographics of
the voters in that right 25
25 a full quarter of the voters uh were
from citizens naturalized citizens born
outside the country so
you know what's happening at the
southern border what's happening across
you know red states what's happening in
these environments that uh people are
leaving right so like where are your
swing states where where are your swing
states where are your swing
demographics there's nobody regardless
of anything or any policies anything
that the biden administration can do
there's no republican or libertarian or
independent that's ever going to win
really ever again probably in my
lifetime in new jersey
in new york
in michigan
and i mean they've gotten maybe michigan
it's going to be very why is that what's
the cause of that because at the end of
the day everyone gets one vote political
strategy so one of the reasons again
these people are not stupid right the
people running these places are not
stupid
phil murphy let's just use jersey for an
example this guy that name this guy i
know don't say that name gerard he knows
exactly what he's doing he knows that
people are leaving his state all right
he knows five years in a row new jersey
has left has led the nation and people
leaving his state this literally his
population is telling him i would rather
live anywhere else but with you that
should be in in a normal governing
environment that should be a massive red
flag that our policies aren't working
instead the policies are working to
their end where they have nothing but
their voters left
so in these places a lot of precedent
that we had before people couldn't pick
up and leave during the oregon trail
times you know just because they didn't
like herbert humphrey they weren't
hopping on a you know horse and buggy
and hightailing it 3000 miles south now
you can so a lot of a lot of what's
happening now in politics a lot of
what's happening behind the scenes you
can't look at past analytics they're not
predictive at this point right they the
democratic party specifically has done
two things they are a big tent party
they they are the party of yes and
juxtaposed themselves against
republicans which are the party of no
okay where do you think you want yes
absolutely 75 genders of course there
are the gas and the breaks right yeah
they're the party of yes okay
and
what they do is once they have control
they squeeze out all opposition small
business get the f out don't watch it
you small business owners you guys are
gone you guys are our opposition
independent voters gone get out of here
i want a constituency of nothing but
union members teachers cops that's it
all right i want i want there to be
three shops i want amazon and every
freaking corner that's that's their
strategy i think small small business
owners got to stop bitching is what they
got to do they got to figure it out i
think small business owners if they
can't pay the minimum wage you know to
people they got to pay them higher hey
man you know you got to compete i think
you got to compete yeah i'm i'm okay
let me let me go to let me go sorry for
your taco shop bro
let me know better tacos let me let me
go to this let me go to this part where
we're talking about biden and i know
you're big on approval ratings so you
used to always bring it up so how
biden's slumping approval rating stacks
up against past presidents this is a
fortune story joe biden entered the
white house writing a wave of popularity
his day one approval rating was 53
percent was well above outgoing
president donald trump's 38.7 approval
rating but the honeymoon phase is over
as of thursday biden's approval rating
stands at 44.2 percent at the same point
in the first term president ronald
reagan was at 55 6. bush was at 67 6.
clinton was at 50.2 george w bush uh
was at 82 9 barack obama was at 52-3 all
much higher approval ratings meanwhile
biden's current rating is a bit higher
than trump's
38.1 rating was on day 261 in office so
far so far biden's slipping approval
rating has yet to give republicans a big
2022 midterm edge in the past four
midterms elections
uh the president's political party lost
congressional seats so i mean this is
kind of telling you what's going to
happen what's not going to happen
if it continues going this way i think a
big part of this has to do with the
economy and these these ships these
ships are bigger than people think it is
these ships is not like yeah this is not
like a small thing we're talking about
here with these ships if you go to page
three on what's going on at la
the port of los angeles will launch 24 7
operations to tackle the huge line of
ship ships waiting to dock the white
house says insider story the port of la
is starting to process ships 24 24 hours
a day seven days a week to help ease a
massive backlog the white house said
wednesday the new hours would most
almost double the number of hours during
the which cargo can be moved it's set
the shipping industry is currently in
chaos which ports in southern california
hit especially hard at the port of la
alone ships current carrying nearly 500
000 shipping containers
containers by the way each one of them
are right now what's the number she said
40 grand a pop 500 000 containers at 40k
a pop or about 12 million metric tons of
goods were waiting in drift areas at an
anchor
on october 5th for spots to open up so
that they could dock and unload on
tuesday there were 80 ships at anchor or
drift area and 64 adverts across both
the ports of la and long beach the
normal number of container ships at
anchors between zero and one yesterday
saki was being asked if uh if things are
not going to be delivered by christmas
and they promise this will never happen
this will never happen and then she
changed her position yeah so well
there's nothing we can do about this
people are just gonna have to accept
that you're not gonna have that's right
so can you imagine like
hey you ordered
if you want to get gifts for your kids
you got to get them now because if you
wait till december you are not it's
going to be january 17th
you're going to get the gifts to give to
your kids so this is a big deal this is
a big deal my mom actually worked in
cargill services for a company called
sealand csx lines horizon lines that now
has been acquired by matson and she
worked with the longshoremen
wednesday nights friday nights just to
make sure that she would watch
physically see with the longshoremen the
last container to be on that ship
and i've been to panama got to see the
canal understand that yeah the money
that is probably being
um
the people who own the ports have to
charge these people for the ships not
leaving
so there's a cost in that as well that
is going to be
driven to the consumer eventually
and it's not going to look good for
people
at all at all the the those uh shipyards
that whatnot they're making the money
right now but i don't know how that's
being dispersed yeah but typically when
someone charges one individual it always
gets hit with us and then you got people
in government that say oh yeah you know
you're not going to be able to get stuff
it's like man it's beyond that you're
talking about medical supplies you're
talking about a lot of different things
and that the future does not look bright
until they get a handle on this thing
yeah i said something earlier man i love
this line you said
i don't come from the hopeless the
helpless community i don't come from the
helpless community it's a great line and
you got jen sackey up there who has all
the access the power of the united
states government could declare a state
of emergency they're going to fire all
the nurses and the doctors and they're
not worried about that because we're
going to replace them with the national
guard well the national guard could
unload trucks the national guard could
unload ships don't don't give me this
people are just gonna have to accept
christmas is canceled this year no
unload the ships who said christmas is
cancelled gensake i'm i am she said yeah
i'm being hyperbolic
but that was a conversation because
because a lot of these bigger
corporations are saying
listen
some of the stuff may not make it to the
stores like you have to be prepared for
it someone said there's going to be a
big delay on that it's not this is not
like a hypothetical this effects
everything this is business yeah this is
affecting everybody so this is the part
where dude did you hear the weight 500
000 containers which is how many tons
did it say what was the tons it was one
point what one problem was 12 million
million metric tons of goods yeah 12
million metric tons of goods so
businesses want to sell i had a guy that
was the the kai the guy that would we
had on elite mastermind he says i sell
cigarette lighters
but he buys quarter million of them and
these cigarette lighters have team logos
on there lakers bowls whatever right
anybody does he says my 250 000 lighters
have already been sold but my customers
are asking for the money back because
it's been 90 days because it's sitting
on a ship and i can't take it off this
is not a millionaire he does 400 000 a
year
and he nets like 120 000 so it's not
like he's a guy making a lot of money
right he has no control over that what
does he do this is affecting a lot of
small business owners normally you would
have to like in the supplement business
it's kind of the same thing you know you
have distributors whatnot and a lot of
the time if you're good
those same distributors sell to those
stores so therefore
by the time the ship actually hits the
port of that destination
everything's already sold you know like
everybody makes their money but in this
case like you just said i mean this guy
now has to have
to
pay back if he even does and this is
going to [ __ ] his business i
literally just did this i got the custom
chucks man yep and uh i ordered two more
of them and it's been six weeks i just
put in like last two and they're not
answering my emails they're not putting
in the refund request the [ __ ] my chucks
are probably sitting on a chip a ship in
the port of l.a that is crazy and you
can't even pay you came in
that's one ship okay one ship can put
eleven hundred boeing 747 planes on
there
what essentially what what this means
are you you can kill the capacity goods
on that ship would take eleven hundred
planes to get it down oh i got you
it would take 35 8 000 foot long trains
it would take eleven thousand four
hundred heavy trucks these ships are big
deals well i think i think i remember
kyle look this up because i don't want
to get this wrong wow but each
uh transcontinental trip that they take
from from china let's say to the west
coast i think it's the equivalent
in carbon emissions of like a million
cars
each of these boats i could be wrong
because i know that sounds crazy they
burn they burn worse fuel they burn
diesel they burn like the crappiest fuel
because they can do that internationally
and they're just they're sitting
out there just burning this stuff up
it's still the most efficient way to
move it like there's no way what are you
gonna do about it we haven't figured out
a better way well there's nothing we can
do look not a shipping expert over here
but what's the root cause of this what's
the supply chain issue are these trade
policies are these
uh is this coveted that's getting in the
middle like why is this all happening
one of the things that they're saying is
people are not showing up employees
the lack of getting it's what we're
talking about people are not showing up
to come and do the work but it's a
backlog even though people are showing
up now yeah it's a backlog of six months
of people not sure this is a systematic
of what happened during covet
unemployment people sitting at home
people not showing up to work people not
moving things okay this is building so
as people as people get back to work
this can get rectified soon is this is
there end in sight here what's the
what's the give me a silver lining here
from since we're not helpless or
hopeless go ahead kai yes and no
obviously if you're if you're trying not
in the short term
yeah if you're if you're putting in the
same amount of 40 hours of week but
you're trying to catch up on six months
of backlog then obviously it's gonna
take a long time to speed that up so
unless you're filling up to try to catch
up it's gonna be a long time and at that
point you might as almost try to trash
it because who knows what the goods of
how long they're shopping for those
perishable goods no
shipping cost now you're going to pay
overtime to the long story almost all
are you thinking about the perishable
goods so if you have a product like i'm
always going to go back to sports
nutrition
from manufacturing data is two years
so you got six months or whatever i mean
it's gonna take
maybe a couple months just to have it
arrive
so you lost two months there
do the math these guys the minute the
protein gets there or whatever how does
that person sell it because the mag
because the person that's buying is
going to be like oh this expires in like
six months
logistics too my buddy's in logistics
ex pro ball player and like uh name's
james what's he said great dude so he
does trucking logistics yeah he somehow
i don't know it exactly but he matches
up trains to to trucks and it's there
it's a bidding war right now there's so
few there's so few truckers and
everybody is trying to force their
products out on overnight delivery
because they're running up against their
their delivery dates there's a certain
amount of shelf life that they have to
be on so they're they're charging like
10 20 000 for a single ride up from like
jacksonville to like charlotte man like
it's insane it's crazy you know how
inflation sometimes is so complicated
this is very simple inflation
because the cost is getting passed down
to who to the business owner and the
business owner is like i can't sell this
thing for seven bucks i got to make it
8.99 i got to make it 9.99 i can't do
nothing about that so these are the
things that is not even linked to
printing money these are the things that
sometimes you just don't have a choice
the small business world is right now
in shambles try your fruit man get a
whole bunch of fruit and drink imagine
nutrition that actually will say i have
the money
to to ship it by air because it needs to
be climate controlled
but damn everybody can't do that yeah so
i mean
it's uh it's really interesting man it's
an interesting thing because
going back to our administration
whenever it comes down to restricting
the rights of individuals they can't
wait to jump they cannot wait to jump
but anytime you need to do the other
side of the pendulum and help people and
like hey let's let's have a solution
that doesn't increase my power they have
absolutely no ideas on how to do it hey
how do we how do we shut down a city i
got 15 ideas on how we're going to do it
everybody's going to wear masks now all
these businesses that have been been
open for six months they got to go
outside build a tent outside because as
long as you're inside outside it's okay
they've got all these ideas but when it
comes to actually being progressive and
pragmatic they got nothing but kiss what
it is sorry christmas is canceled what
do you mean unload the ships
unload the ships
very innovative when it favors you and
no innovation when it doesn't favor you
that's a great point but by the way when
you do things like this long-term states
are going to take a hit tesla will move
its headquarters to texas
elon musk says this is a cnn story
i'm excited to announce that we're
moving our headquarters to austin texas
says elon musk at a shareholder meeting
the electric car company is currently
based in palo alto california he cited
housing affordability and the long
commutes it can create as hurdles for
its current location and said the austin
factory is five minutes away from the
airport in 15 minutes from downtown the
median home prices in palo alto is 3.3
million dollars
whereas the median home prices in austin
is 5.88 let me say that one more time
the median home prices is 3.3
million dollars to 588 despite the move
musk said tesla plans to continue to
significantly expand in california i
think the last comment was made to say
don't hurt me yet till i fully leave
your state just an insurance policy
of a comment so
how many more stories like this is going
to happen because california you guys
heard what uh california is doing
there's some very weird stories yeah
rece it's almost unbelievable like when
i read it i thought tom ellsworth was
sending me another one of his you know
by the way when's the last time you were
in austin
two weeks ago you were there yeah i was
there two weeks ago as well
i have a point
um
i have a point i i obviously was very
awkward the way he did it but
well i have something to say because i
have to grab the grab the box of cookies
where are we at where are we at
obviously
san francisco san jose silicon valley um
palo alto silicon silicon silicon valley
silicon it's crazy crazy expensive i get
it i get it
austin
you can quote me on this they're going
to be dealing with the same issues
they're dealing with california pretty
soon affordability oh yeah homelessness
and traffic that's all i experienced in
austin i'm like i'm ready to have a good
time in austin yeah yeah traffic galore
things are expensive homeless galore
yeah okay so
just
be careful what you wish for elon musk
and people in texas because california's
coming forward college teammate sean
finnegan left jersey for uh
austin texas about 10 years ago and he
was a real estate agent dudes made money
like through the roof man doing
mortgages and real estate and he said
now it's like it's it's nuts it's insane
they never thought to build another road
the infrastructure is still like 20
years old but now they're just building
on top of each other like it's to keep
austin weird is it's uh now it's like
please move out of austin the people
there
nancy our graphic designer said i want
you to play a game while you're in
austin
homeless or hipster hipster homeless or
i couldn't tell the difference half the
time i'm like that guy's clearly hit no
he's homeless i gotta tell that guy
probably i'm a millionaire
same thing homeless or hipster the lady
i got my condo from thought she got one
over on me man she was like you're gonna
pay this for that and i'm i'm paying i
pay 100 more 100
more a month i had a 700 square foot
loft on the hudson river in in jersey
city i pay 100 more for a two-bedroom
2500 square foot two-bedroom two-bath
condo here in pompano and you're on the
beach i'm on the beach and i haven't i
haven't stepped over one hole this guy i
haven't smelled
something
in new jersey florida's not good they
don't need to come here
don't investigate for yourself there's
nothing good going
jersey i on hundred dollars more for a
two bedroom as opposed to you know
denver's the same way like to be honest
i used to live downtown and at one point
i was like
man there's a lot of homelessness and
then shereen i go down there we're like
no these are hipsters so you almost
don't like you say yeah
you definitely don't know the difference
guys are you okay if we give a shout out
to governor newsom can we give a shout
out to you let me read a story it's a
very important story because governor
newsom is so concerned about what's
going on the state this is a reuters
story this is not an onion this is a
reuters story california law prohibits
secretly removing condoms during sex
adam okay this is newsome okay this is a
true story reuters we're really talking
about newsome signed wow a law look how
hard he's working you got to respect
this guy hardcore he signed into a law
bill on thursday that prohibits
stealthing
or removing condom during sex without
consent making it a civil sexual battery
offense it is the first anti-stealthing
law in the country i have been working
on the issue for stealthing since 2017.
and i'm elated guys let me wrap this up
i am elated that there is now some
accountability for those who perpetrate
the act sexual assault especially those
on women of color are perpetually swept
under the rug assemblywoman christina
garcia the bill sponsor said in a
statement
people found guilty of removing condom
without consent could be liable for
general special and punitive damage
damages the law states so by the way
this is great that they're doing this to
protect them because we've all heard
these stories and and i was in the
military so you get stories like this
but
all the fire that's taking place in
california is anybody concerned about
that
all the all the homelessness that's
taken so this is what he's concerned
talk about sequencing and having
priorities in place right i demand he
does something about the lack of gender
neutral toys i mean that's just well
listen let's not stop there because this
man is on a roll so if you want to go
there california demands general neutral
toys
this place at big stores and by the way
this is a cbs news story pull up the
story because people probably don't
believe these stories we've done it he's
taking over he's your governor we've
created equality it's all it's over
california
the first state to say large department
stores must display products like toys
and toothbrushes in general neutral ways
a way for lgbt advocates who say the
pink and blue hues of traditional
marketing methods pressure children to
conform to gender stereotypes the new
law signed by democratic governor
newsome on saturday does not outlaw
traditional boys and girls sections at
department stores instead it says large
stores must also have a general neutral
section and display a reasonable
selection of items regardless of whether
they have been traditionally marketed
for girls or boys the law only applies
to toys and children's uh child care
items so there you have it i mean this
is just fascinating go up again to make
sure we know the story this is uh
yeah this nbc also covers it california
law requires gender neutral areas and
same stores some stores that that felon
doesn't have her mask covering her nose
will the toys even arrive on time
this podcast live would be ahead i just
i'm just saying it i'm just saying so so
california listen what's going on there
i don't know you're people it's my
people
you you were raised there you you
would you spent a lot of time there
would you be open to the idea of moving
to california i'm i'm i'm good in in
this horrible state called florida don't
move here rent or waiver tell people
five reasons why they shouldn't move to
florida give them five reasons why they
shouldn't move so hot all year round
it's crazy there's tons of [ __ ] that
come here from new jersey wink wink
alligators
and alligators everywhere everyone half
the people in the office quit because
they got bit by an alligator it's insane
it's insane the flooding talk about
flooding yeah you don't want to be in
florida right now this is true
on a serious note though i've driven all
across the country i guess i got a
ticket this morning i've got to take it
this morning
i know i'm just it's a public
announcement i got exactly like my 200
hey tickets uh not breaking news packing
another traffic ticket
where were you going 170 and a thousand
anyway
it's a terrible ticket but i got to take
it this morning and we have to now work
on this with my ticket but anyways so
one thing about florida i got to give
credit to the worst drivers oh my ever
expected i kind of
cut off something dude like a guy yeah
girl cut me off yesterday i'm not even
kidding with you i'm just
she's like this
i've never seen this in my life i'm just
looking at her and she's like apologies
i'm like i accept the apology but this
is seriously weird i've never seen then
today this morning a guy cuts up it's
five lane federal i'm coming up from the
furthest lane to the right
to the left turn he just straight up
goes like this yeah yeah i mean so so
the credit goes to they're either nascar
drivers get trained here
formula one drivers they just suck
whenever do you know the reasons why
tell us think about it we've got
retirees galore yeah there's 80 year
olds all these three were under 40k no i
don't accept that you have a lot of
tourists that are just kind of like
going you have a lot of immigrants a lot
of
latinos especially coming from people
just
fyi those are some of the best drivers
because you have to learn how to drive
without laws and lights and all that
stuff they're they're they're the big
okay i don't know why more latino
drivers won the nascar i don't
understand why they don't like there's
got to be a recruitment you got to go to
like a you got to go somebody's got to
go to tj because they don't let low
riders in nascar paddle
rod
sorry my second car i ever bought was a
low rider chevy s10 long bed gold
low profile wheels 140 something spokes
system he had a date i bought it bro i
bought it from a mara
member and my dad says this guy here
he's an artist you'd love this truck you
should come see this artist i go meet
the artist i said why is he an artist he
had tattoos everywhere and he says ms-13
and i said that this guy's with marisa i
said well i love the truck we did a deal
i bought the truck a week later in
hollywood i got arrested helicopters
follow me because they thought i was him
i'm like i'm not part of ms-13 i'm
patrick david he says no you're with
ms-13 i said fine proof i'm with ms-13
it took us like three o'clock in the
morning to let us go they really thought
we were ms-13 yeah no tats
no tats would you ever get a tat gabriel
look gangsters how though
does look gangster
would i would i get a tat uh yeah maybe
one day and if i do if i do it would
have to have a meaning let's just say
dylan wants to get one and he wants to
do with the daddy i would entertain it
but it's not listen so many times i try
to get a tattoo
i can tell the story of you shouldn't
get tattoos it's not acceptable i
probably tried to get a tattoo in the
army 50 times but i just spent way too
much money on alcohol and partying i was
always broke to get a tattoo if i
probably had 200 to my name i probably
would have had six tattoos right now but
the only reason that you don't have
tattoos because you were broke in the
army by the time i was twenty
drinking i have tattoos
i have tattoos because i drew
by the time i hit 21 years old did you
ever get a tattoo on your uh gifted body
oh man
i've thought about it many times yeah i
think like i played college basketball
and everybody had tattoos yeah oh
basketball players have tattoos yeah
that's crazy i know right but then but
then after a while you know obviously
being a bodybuilder i'm like i'm not
doing that
i'm at a point in time in my life where
i feel like there's meaning to it
a lot more um just haven't found the
right you know phrase or right image
but i'm not opposed to doing it at some
point in time i'm just uh i'm just
contemplating it i think i think you
ought to get a tattoo on your forearm
that says what's your point
just remind you what's my point
you know what it is though if you
haven't at this point i think you know
if you don't want to get it well after
after would you get a tattoo just one
teardrop right here just
because of what happened two weeks ago
yeah it's tough spend a little too much
time with sammy yeah
[Laughter]
sorry about that sammy no tattoo i
remember being 16 south beach my boy's
like i'm going to get a either a eyebrow
piercing or tattoo you're coming with me
i'm like okay
he's like all right i'm going we went to
a place called tattoos by lou famous
like place here in miami again 16th
south beach he went he got the um
like a yeah eyebrow piercing
your boy saw us fainted right now
just i'm like i believe that i'm like
i'm just oh so you wouldn't get it
because of pain i can't see no no i'm
not the pain
bothers you it was just the tattoo shot
it was just wasn't it it wasn't you were
traumatized
and also being jewish that's frowned
upon yeah in the jewish community yeah
you know trump said three things to his
kids don't drink don't do drugs and
don't get tattoos and i'll take care of
you okay that was as well i agree with
one of those
which one is that drugs the tattoo thing
[Laughter]
levar ball actually i'm guilty of the
other time for tattoos really uh jello
i think i think there is something to
say because everybody has them if you
don't have them more because it's more
unique the pressure is more for those
that don't have them than those that do
have them let's just kind of put it
there okay so another very important
story that just i mean very very
important story that i think we need to
cover here
is uh uh old mafia guys think texting
has ruined the mob okay this is this is
a true story old mafia you guys think
texting has ruined them up it's common
knowledge that the new york's infamous
five families aren't quite
what they used to be uh worn down by the
feds upstart competitors and a changing
world in general according to the wall
street journal though they have another
problem the goddamn youngs and their
cell phones this is truly the article i
just read the article the paper wrote
that today's new roster of gangsters
isn't exactly impressing the old guard
especially because
some lacked the sense to not leave
incriminating text messages or logs
behind a new generation of wise guys
didn't properly
learn the business older members
complained that the millennials who grew
up in the suburbs instead of the city
streets are softer dumber and not as
loyal as mobsters of the past plus
they're always texting everything is on
the phone with them said a former made
uh member of the colombo family so
do you agree with these guys it's it's i
mean gerard's half mafia i tell you man
go ahead i i do but i think it's the
camera phones more anything else but
it's like there's kids i used to coach
and i would tell them like listen you
want to go to college college coaches
they're going to scrub your social media
and like it's like i couldn't even get
the sentence out before we'd see them on
instagram or snapchat like yeah at this
party yeah vibing bro it's a vibe and
i'm like dude like there's booze
everywhere you're 16. what are you doing
i just couldn't understand it on like
i couldn't wrap my brain around the
things i used to do to try to sneak into
the house right and not be detected when
i was out with my friends or we had like
a couple drinks or something like that
because it's a real skill though yeah
and then you're coming in and like
you're doing the mouthwash like your
parents don't know oh yeah yeah you're
doing mouthwash
yeah exactly so they can get up to the
lines the things that we did to try to
keep our dirt secret and these guys
lived their whole life on front street
you know good for them i guess man but i
can just see it i can see the millennial
mobster being like hey man about to go
axe this dude shouldn't have done what
he's doing like i got my gun right i got
my gun right here this is the gun i'm
using right now you know what it reminds
me that's that's that's that's that's
that's nice of no strip bro remember the
um the scene in um
in goodfellas when they when they do
like the big thing they go to layla for
a little while we don't need you you
know putting getting eyeballs on us and
the guy shows up in the big fur coat
yeah it's like i [ __ ] told you
what are you doing here
at this point it's uh because it's a
sign of the time social media snapchat
instagram tick tock yeah
if you did something and you don't put
it on social media did it even really
happen yeah so validation it's putting
out there like the cell phone has killed
the mob yeah straight up it's killed
marriages yeah it's killed the
institution of marriage it's killed i
mean the cell phone is like we are
living in the panopticon and also it
goes the other way too dude what gerard
just don't say that word and pretend
that anyone understands you used
diatribe the other day yeah but the
problem is you're uh you use these words
and you know nobody knows what
panopticon what is it a transformer what
is that private school i live at school
i will challenge people anybody else any
of our listeners privates who tell me
what's going on
your dad expected you to learn a word a
day that's more than standard
no this is the truth it's supposed to
read the dictionary every day
i want us all just to find this
gerard got upset because i said
and then he said
uh clear clearly and the uh the
asparagus they fight like a copticon in
these zeitgeist a lot of times yeah what
is it it's a change
it's a transformer thank you all right
the uh so
so anyway
do you know what that is kai i can't
spell it
i have a friend of mine who had her her
daughter had a sleepover and they had
cameras installed like in the basement
to make sure nobody snuck out and i'm
like no i'm trying to explain her i'm
like sarah the whole point of having a
sleepover is to like sneak out like
that's you gotta let kids be kids like
you're you're you're putting these
people underneath
is a disciplinary concept brought to
life in the form of a central
observation tower placed with a circle
of prison cells
the panopticon you're constantly under
surveillance oh my gosh oh my god great
shortcomings are you serious right now
are you guys serious you don't know i
understand
might have become i'm so sorry i didn't
know he was gonna drink before yeah
if i get am i getting knocked i don't
have my good vocabulary what's going on
i gotta get out of here i gotta go take
a panopticon all right
guys by the way yesterday i was being
interviewed on a podcast the guy's
interviewing me he says look
i'm so sorry i've never done this before
i got to go pee so bad
i want you to know you just made history
today i've been interviewed hundreds of
times no one's had to pause to get up
and go peace so you made history good
for yourself [ __ ] i feel bad you got to
talk about it i said i'm definitely do
we also made you do like 15 up fronts at
the end
oh my god i'm like dude i'm done
nice guy yeah nice guy okay let's do
this last one here wrap up america's
trust in media dips to second lowest on
record this is a gallop americans trust
the media to the uh to report the news
fully accurately and fairly has etched
down four percent points to last year's
36 percent making this year's
reading the second lowest in gallup's
trend in all seven percent of all u.s
adults say they have a great deal and a
29 percent a fair amount of trust and
confidence in newspapers television and
radio news reporting which combines four
points about 32 percent which uh record
low in 2016 amid the divisive
presidential campaign between trump and
hillary clinton in addition 29 percent
public uh currently registers not very
much trust uh and 34 have not at all so
meaning
to simplify this math they confuse the
[ __ ] out of everybody 36 percent trust
the rest do not trust 1972 in 1976 68 to
72 percent of americans expressed trust
in the mass media that's a pretty crazy
number 72 and 76
nearly 70 percent of americans trusted
the media yet by 1997 when the question
was next asked the trust had dropped to
in 20 years it dropped 20 percent
trusted media which has averaged 45
since 19 1997 has not reached the
majority level since 2003 guys 36 it's a
scary thought to think the number right
now i mean do you trust the media do you
trust the media if yes who do you trust
in the media who is today's cronkite
that you follow in the media this is
well i think it's not good this is 1972.
yeah i'll just kick this off the the
it's this is good and bad i'll give you
the good the good the bad the algae the
good
or the bad is that in 1972 you had
three major outlets right you had the
big three cbs nbc abc
okay
we all about choice here all right so
then fox show we're not all about some
people cnn up
um
ted turner a
fan of the show um
and then obviously
boom the cat was out the bag you have i
mean back in the day when when we were
growing up how many channels were on tv
10 20 30 at the most now there's
literally a thousand so options go lower
so the point is this is now you can go
live in your own echo chamber you can go
to your breitbart and that's where you
get your news or you can go to your
msnbc and that's where you get your news
or you can go to whatever you
are getting your your confirmation bias
and you can just get your news there
the options are good the different media
outlets are good but the fact like this
is we say this all the time
i'll watch fox i don't like tucker but
i'll watch tucker
i don't love uh everything that's on fox
news i'll watch it though i watch cnn i
watch nbc i get my information from
multiple sources like you always say
is find something you agree with now go
find the exact opposite thing and
that'll enhance your argument but i wish
my my final point is here i wish we'd
get to a point where at least there's
some
agreement on facts right now it's just i
think there should be disclaimers this
is an opinion show hannity should be an
opinion show don le mans should be a
opinion show that's not news five
o'clock news or even the five that's all
opinions so the that that's
there's the good the bad and the ugly of
this i think there should be a
disclaimer if it's opinion versus actual
news i don't even know what is actually
the problem is that the fact checkers do
we even trust them
there's that part we thought by fact
checking that we could trust what the
media or whoever is saying
we're who do you trust myself i trust
myself no seriously i trust myself to be
able to do the research and actually be
a free thinker on a lot of these topics
and actually raise my freaking hand and
say you know what i wasn't right
and i think what's happening right now
is that some people are realizing man
i used to watch this show and then i
realized they're full of [ __ ]
and then i watched this show and i
realized the same thing so it's better
that i do both and i you know decipher
and use discernment and figure this out
but until we get to the point where
people can be called out on both sides
and and actually come like when you said
and actually say a spade is a spade and
then people gerard you really had a good
point the other day you and i were just
talking about this briefly and uh you
know people will see a spade and then
they'll be like nah i still ain't gonna
accept this and i think that's the
problem
you know like even with the world the
way it is i mean we have a you know
we're talking alcovid and stuff it's
like the survival rate is so good right
now we should be celebrating
not acting like
we're in doom and gloom
you know and it's just the way that the
the echo chambers are you know and they
just want to say what they want to say
well i mean there's two things two
stories that we didn't get to cover
today but that'll that'll explain kind
of why that is that way right there's
china appears set to ban reporting by
news outlets not directly funded by the
communist party and there's also katie
kirk coming out and admitting that she
buried uh ruth bader ginsburg story on
uh
you know ruth bader ginsburg was very
very uh adamant that the players
shouldn't kneel she was very uh
boisterous and in her disappointment in
colin kaepernick and katie corey
admitted kitty kirk admitted to burying
that story because she thought it would
be a bad look for
ruth bader ginsburg so she again that's
not reporting the news that's
manipulation that's social engineering
the 35 people who trust the news right
now you guys are wrong
the the trust in our news should be zero
it doesn't mean you shouldn't listen it
means you shouldn't trust okay you let
you hear tucker cross you say all right
that makes sense this doesn't make sense
and then like you guys said you go find
a second and third now pat i have one
request from you if you do buy that
media company if you do buy that print
overt bias whoever they are there they
don't get to hide behind this guys of
journalism they don't get to hide behind
this guise of objectivity it's gone it's
over overt bias all right two things
whatever they're registered or whoever
whatever politicians they've donated to
has to be in their byline anderson
cooper registered democrat donated x y z
then whatever they say has we can
understand that it's coming from that
perspective the other thing is user
interaction if you get a story the user
should be able to go to to point to to
click right or left 78 of readers said
that this is a right-leaning article 72
percent of readers said this is a
left-wing that's the plan that's the
plan actually what we want to do but i
think uh the current state of things in
the media panepticon it's it's a little
bit
[Applause]
you know
it's a little challenging
he left me a message about pinocchio and
that's speaking
got a text message from my mom uh this
morning goes why'd you lose my number
he's giving you that jewelry i gotta
call you i gotta call you mom my bad can
i can i we probably gotta wrap up i'm
gonna say one thing about the the china
and everything with that yeah when i was
at that freedom forum the other day
there's a something called the firewall
project where they'll they'll side by
side
they will put up google and then what
google is in china and they'll let you
look an image
of uh
something in america and then show you
what they show in china and it's
completely
different you talk about propaganda or
brainwashing like so for instance you've
seen the uh you'll probably appreciate
this you've seen the image of she
next to winnie the pooh you've seen that
he kind of looks like him a little bit
so if you do that in the american google
it pops right up you put that in china
zero percent will that pop up zero
percent i mean you can try it right now
she winning the pool i'm sure you'll get
this thing right boom zero images of
that in china and then we went on and on
and on and on of different like even
with trump with trump in america
um
they'll they'll be
the good the bad the ugly of trump uh
images like
all the images in china where comb over
flying over
evil you know fire and fury it's just
china's controls what happens
google something in america and then
duckduckgo it and see how different the
results you get 10 seconds guys so i'm
glad you brought that point up fantastic
now i got to get that image out of my
head with xi and we need to pull all day
today
but anyways i don't think
can't hear you buddy david's censoring
you david is answering you go ahead just
use your name at the panopticon and then
yeah yeah keep using our wardrobe okay
so we don't have podcasts next tuesday
we may next thursday stay tuned uh for
the 100th episode we're going to do a
special episode so hang tight we'll
announce what the special episode's
going to be for the 100 episodes
probably a couple weeks from now but we
will not be together next tuesday so
enjoy your weekend
away tell your friends tell your kids
it'd be great for 100 episodes to
celebrate a hundred thousand dollars
i'll be great it'd be great
we want to get to 100 if it gets to 100
we'll do multiple more than just two a
week we'll try to figure out something
about the schedule but uh we will talk
to you guys in a week from today have a
great weekend everybody take care bye
bye bye
you